at the time there was a little bit of a
sort of Rumblings in the medical world
around sort of this idea of big data and
how it applies to like patient data and
like enormous blood test results that we
have going back like decades and how to
get insights from that and CU I was sort
of interested in technology I was like
oh maybe this could be an angle that I
kind of talk about thankfully they never
ask me any questions about it cuz I
really wasn't prepared but well you
didn't do so bad you got in anyway but
um but the but it was around that time
it was around 2011 I was writing the
book big data 2012 it came out out so
it's about a decade old it's still not
there which is sort of interesting the
the the intellectual underpinnings of
using data in society to improve Society
is sort of understood but to actually
make social change takes a long time
takes decades in the case of medicine
we're still not using information I mean
we use it in a pointless way like a an
internist will walk by the the bedside
of a person in the hospital would pick
up a clipboard or the digital equivalent
of it um and will look at the at the
numbers and make a decision on it and
that's ridiculous and obscene because
really what you want to do is to have
every single person who's had that exact
same condition and meets the same
criteria of the patient going back a
decade and you would then have a sort of
a co-pilot if you will as the term that
we now use in terms of using AI to
support human
beings would to then make its own
estimation and you might want to Blind
the two and see if the two decisions in
of the next therapy and next you know
diagnostic uh is the same in which
you're confirming it or then to if you
have a difference add a third person a
Minority Report if you will a third
person to make a decision on it to vote
in One Direction or the other and then
to use the feedback of what happened was
it the right diagnostic or not and of
course it's never white or black so you
so it's it's a it's a spectrum of rsh or
wrongish what what are the Alternatives
you don't know the counterfactual and
then to feed that back in to the next
person Google does this for search so if
you if everyone starts clicking on the
second search result for the same search
term or better yet if everyone's
clicking on the eighth search result for
a given search term Google the algorithm
knows to move it up to the first or
second place because it's clearly the
most popular each click is a vote so why
don't we do that in healthcare it's
crazy and again it's obscene because all
it takes is the will and a bit of do and
we improve patient outcomes and we
improve society and we lower our costs m
yeah yeah I think there's there's so
much here where um like whenever anyone
I know for me as well whenever we start
working in medicine and we see the
amount of data that is available and
then see the fact that it's all you know
in the UK some of it is still in pen and
paper system some of it you have to use
four different apps to access like your
blood tests and then the sort of the
vital signs of the patient and another
one for your scans and another one for
the drug stuff and it's like there are
very few systems that integrate all the
things and the ones that do like I I was
working in Cambridge at Aden Brook's
hospital that did integrate all the
things and it was incredible I could run
my whole night shift from like the cafe
Burger King downstairs cuz it always
have Burger Kings in hospital for some
reason and just like on the iPad because
they it had an iPad app was you know
someone bring me about a patient I'd be
able to immediately see all the things
it still wasn't co-pilot and that it
wasn't telling me what to do next but
even just the basics of just having all
the information in one place was a
really good starting point um yeah well
we might not for keep in mind we might
not want it to be a full co-pilot system
particularly for you at the outset of
your career we wanted you to make
decisions in fact we sort of sadly want
you to make mistakes because if you make
mistakes when you're young you probably
won't when you're old what we would like
to do is maybe validate your decision or
have you reconsider your decision right
so if the you know if the if you think
that this person has gallstones and in
fact it turns out it's septice right and
anyone could see it a mile away and your
supervisor would but it's 4 in the
morning right we want the AI system and
or in this case the Big Data System to
Simply prod you and say have you
considered septus right and and we you
say ah yeah maybe maybe that's right and
you can reconsider um it might want to
tell you its confidence it's its its
degree of confidence in its diagnosis in
which it says that actually we think
it's different but it's really only with
a 60% likelihood or degree of confidence
in this instance where you're quite sure
that it's actually not this for this
other intervening reason uh the toxicity
of the patient would kill him if you
were to give that particular drug for
example um those are the ways in which
we would use data effectively but it
requires two things one probably a
regulatory change we need to sort of
loosen privacy rules in certain wise
ways that are still governed under very
strict law but loosened for this social
goal uh Privacy Law never presumed a
world of statistics and presumed
commercial rapaciousness it didn't
really it doesn't really accept the idea
that with a large body the Big Data
message which is or if you will lead
Motif with a large body of data you can
do things that you inherently can't do
with a smaller amount of it it's not
about the point list sliver of
information but the a glomeration of a
large body of data asking new questions
answering them in more um deeper and
more accurate ways than we ever could
and granular ways than we ever could
imagine that's the first the bigger
problem is a is a change of mindset m we
need if you will a data duty of care
mindset and that is to
say we can't accept a world in which um
we're going to make human decisions and
we're going to try to validate those
decisions with a smidgen of information
that confirms what we think we're
looking at we we reframe it we inverse
the reverse the process if you will and
say that it's not a nice to have it's a
thou must have you have a legal and
moral responsibility
to apply data to questions that we can
use the data to help us answer and if
you don't you're negligent and on the
hawk so it's not like a doctor says um
here's my decision and here's how I
Justified it with the data but it says
this here's my decision and if I didn't
use data to confirm it and to validate
it I have not performed my duty of care
to my patient and I go to jail or I'm
I'm on for on the hawk for liability
if we had a world like that you would
never have an environment in which
patients go in and hope the best for
whoever is making a blur ey decision at
4 in the morning because you're always
going to have this sort of support
mechanism of every single data point the
NHS has collected over the last decade
for every patient that looks like mine
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great take